okay we're breaking into this uh report
to bring you a story out of new zealand
a man has been shot and killed by new
zealand police after he stabbed several
people at a supermarket the new zealand
prime minister jacinda ardan is speaking
from auckland let's listen to what she's
got to say
this afternoon i want to share what we
know about this event
but also what we know about the
terrorists
but first i want to acknowledge these
six innocent people who have been
attacked
three i understand are seriously injured
this was a violent attack it was
senseless and i am so sorry it happened
the attack began at 2 40 p.m
and was undertaken by an individual who
was a known threat to new zealand
the individual was under constant
monitoring
and it was the police surveillance team
and special tactics group who were part
of that monitoring and surveillance that
shot and killed him within i'm told the
space of roughly 60 seconds of the
attack starting
for the detail of the events today i
will pass to commissioner andrew costa
to provide detail of the special tactics
group operation
i'll then say more of what we know about
the terrorists
and the government's efforts to protect
new zealanders from him
thank you prime minister
as the prime minister has said this
individual was under heavy surveillance
as a consequence of concerns about his
ideology
today he traveled from where he lived in
glendon
to the countdown in new lin
as he had done before
he was closely watched by surveillance
teams
and
a tactical team to release what we can
but they will provide additional insight
into this attack
before i open up four questions what
happened today was despicable it was
hateful it was wrong
it was carried out by an individual
not a faith
not a culture
not an ethnicity but an individual
person who is gripped by ideology that
is not supported here by anyone or any
community
he alone carries the responsibility for
these acts
let that be where the judgment falls
jessica
can you give us a scale of what the
person was planning to do
we've had absolutely uh nothing that
would tell us the extent of his
intentions or indeed that he had
uh particular intentions today to go and
do this act
based on our surveillance what we could
tell is that he was undertaking what
appeared to be a normal shopping
expedition however clearly we have been
concerned about his ideology and that's
why he was under surveillance and with
accompanying tactical teams to be able
to
at home they'll look at this and say if
he was being surveyed and so closely
watched why did it why were six people
able to be injured before he was shot
can you explain that this individual is
very surveillance conscious and
surveillance teams
working with an offender over an
extended period of weeks need to
maintain sufficient distance for that
surveillance to be effective
so they were as close as they possibly
could be without compromising the
surveillance operation so this is
someone that has been closely monitored
and so as the commissioner has said um
there was nothing that we're aware of at
this point in time to indicate that what
he was going to do today was going to
happen today but obviously because he
was being uh closely followed and
watched they were there at the vicinity
in the supermarket at the time that this
occurred
that he was recently released from jail
can you confirm that um and
commissioners following on from jesus
question if this man was on a terror
watch list why was he in the community
i had prepared a timeline of everything
that we know of this individual and his
interaction with our agencies and the
law
i've been advised that because of
suppression orders i can't share that
with you today but i i do undertake
to go away and find a way that i can
share that with you i think it's in
everyone's best interest that i'm able
to do so i just can't do it right now
unfortunately when they're issued by the
courts it's the court's order so i as
i've said
i prepared a timeline for you that i
wanted to share and i intend to share
with you i just unfortunately need to go
through a process before i can
i'm just
following that question why was someone
who was on a terror watch list out in
the community i'm confident that we have
done absolutely everything we can within
the bounds of the law
and operationally
to ensure that
we could prevent what occurred with this
individual but
there was nothing to prevent him being
in the community and we were doing
absolutely everything possible to
monitor him and indeed
the fact that we were able to intervene
so quickly in roughly 60 seconds shows
just how closely we were watching when
we're in the position to do so you'll
see at every point every attempt we've
made to use the law to the greatest
extent we could
the fact that he was in the community uh
will be an illustration of the fact that
we haven't succeeded in using the law to
the extent we would have liked that is
why he was being closely monitored at
all times uh and so that is given he was
in the community but been closely
monitored at all times he had a
surveillance team monitoring him and a
special tactics group that you can see
was at the supermarket at the time he
was there
i'll let you finish that question does
that mean that that mosque
was also under police surveillance and i
think a lot of people will be concerned
about a backlash against the muslim
community perhaps that would be that
would be wrong
that would be absolutely wrong
the community here has been nothing but
helpful and supportive it would be wrong
to
direct
any frustration and anyone beyond this
individual that is who is culpable that
is who is responsible
uh
violent ideology uh and isis-inspired
and you're confident he was a lone wolf
actor yes you're watching arden zero
we've been bringing you a press
conference being held by new zealand
prime minister jacinda arden
from wellington in new zealand following
an attack at a supermarket in auckland
where several people have been stabbed a
man had been shot and killed by new
zealand police
the prime minister they're describing it
as an individual known
to be under constant monitoring it was a
hateful and wrong attack